season four if you had to boil it down
to one word how would you describe the
season miss a newly you are broken what
is going to be the big drama this year
that we're gonna be talking about week
after week after week
but yeah but women but you know all of
the above literally
but Michael likes big butts I cannot
live her life it's a mess are you okay
with what Michael dated we're breaking
the fourth wall a little bit because
your real life and the camera life kind
of intertwined will not yours
the Darby's okay some allegations that
he has denied the charges have been
dropped right how did that affect the
group having all that play out I think
it affected us realistically I always
said I needed Michael B to be totally
vindicated so I'm looking forward to
that yeah it was kind of difficult
because when you're looking at the
cameras and the people who are in your
home and then it kind of lets you
realize that wow I really don't know the
people that are in my home who I'm
working with and then when you see and
you see in the news like actual charges
being brought up and it was very surreal
I'm really interested in seeing how this
unfolds for myself because I mean being
in the midst of it all it was like a
reality check
within the reality show right it's not a
position I envy that they're in but I'm
sure the Darby's will be fine I've been
in the position before where people are
trying to judge or pass judgment we've
all been there so you know it's like
everybody gets a turn if it is a [ __ ]
interesting you say Karma's a [ __ ]
because that is Ashley's tackling this
year
but luckily I'm on her good side walking
in her truth and I have to say even
though Ashley and I have not always seen
eye-to-eye she's trying to walk in her
truth and understands that you know some
of the things that she did in the past
is unacceptable and she's making or
attempting to make amends for that we've
done baby you may be like oh book I saw
yesterday broke version of Tina no
for three seasons Ashley has been
vindictive malicious and a liar and the
growth I see in her even caused me to
pause before I become judgemental with
her and that just you know lifts me as a
human being because I have every reason
to lynch her and could do it well but I
pause I pause because I see a genuine
effort in that direction to change what
is wrong about her and she's making that
conscious decision to change that
you might want to help your husband I am
looking forward to an all of the guys
all of the lives come out yeah and then
revealed and I'm like yes vindication
hello it's refreshing so just know that
the truth is finally gonna get out there
and I think the viewers are gonna be
really happy with how they see things
unfold so maybe what we saw play out in
the press while you guys were filming is
not what we're gonna see as the reality
and say that you're gonna see a lot of
ups and downs back and forth mixed
emotions it's kind of like a roller
coaster it's not a forgiving it's yeah a
lot of yeah you're going you're gonna
see us like wow it's actually happening
you're gonna literally see how we
process the information we will receive
it and I think the audience will find
that relatable because it shows personal
growth in all of us right except for two
[Laughter]
you